- Alex clearly, it's how to
last to go fact on people.
So at what moment did you realize
the first movie was
just such a phenomenon?
- Well, they, we made the first movie,
and then the studio that we
made it for went bankrupt
and it was shelved.
And Keanu and I were told
that it was never going to come out, ever.
And so we had, kind of moved on,
taking a deep breath and said,
"Okay, well that was a fun experience."
And then, it suddenly got
picked up and kinda pulled out.
And I think I was in Austin
shooting and music video,
the weekend that it come out.
And I walked indoor like a road house,
I think just to get like
a, water or something
I wasn't eating there.
And the whole place like,
hundreds of picnic tables,
just went nuts.
- As Clarksons, we love it.
- (mumbles) my shoulder.
And yeah, and I'd been
running from it ever since.
(all laughing)
- Running to it, it's ...
- To it, to it. Yeah, it's all right.
Yes.
- Yes, yes.
So Keanu, what about you? Cause
I mean I know allota times
in our careers, all of us here
you'll be in above of all of something
and you're not really
realized the impactive error.
How broad that this could,
like how broad it reaches.
What about you, when did
you kinda first realize,
"This is like a big deal."
- I think it's when
you're just locked in it.
When you're kinda just
walking down the street
and people are yelling
out of cars, that shit!
Dude, be excellent, party on.
Dude, excellent, party on.
- That's me, you know that right?
That I'm the one doing that.
- Yeah it's actually, yeah.
They paid your family to make
you feel good about yourself.
(laughing)